spectacle pur ensuite pour jean pierre
melville 20 ans de cinéma melville pères
de la nouvelle vague un petit peu
peut-être beaucoup malville c'est le
silence de la mer c'est le doulos s'est
plus récemment le deuxième souffle il a
dit amaury séveno ce qu'allait être son
prochain film le samouraïs dont alain
delon et la vedette ce décor représente
la chambre de jeff costello le héros du
samouraï le film que je tourne en ce
moment et c'est bien entendu alain delon
qui interprète jeff costello
c'est un décor que je n'ai pas traité
d'une façon réaliste vous en apercevez
temps et qu'il est situé dans le xxème
arrondissement près du métro telegraph
avec la hauteur de plafond par exemple
la forme des fenêtres ma découverte
photographique que vous apercevez à
travers les fenêtres tout ça n'est pas
très vrai on ne se sent pas tout à fait
à paris les spectateurs ne se sentiront
pas à eux ils subiront sans analyser le
dépaysement et un décor va leur procurer
et ça les aidera à s'installer un petit
peu mieux dans le fauteuil vous parliez
tout à l'heure de cette façon qu'on a
d'abord d un film policier en tant que
spectateurs vont arriver parce que les
gens s'assoient un petit peu mieux
qu'ils ne le sont pendant fauteuil de
cinéma c'est une marque d'intérêt à la
poésie aussi pour vous le film policier
oui toute façon je crois que là la
création dans dans le cinéma ne peut
être que poésie
je ne crois pas tout à fait que ce soit
dollar c'est un spectacle poétique
vous êtes d'accord avec hitchcock en
matière de décors tout au moins le
réalisme c'est l'ennemi oui absolument
la phrase d'hitchcock qui est très
exactement quand je vois apparaître l'aï
deux figures de la vraisemblance de lui
tend le cou n'est pas valable que sur le
décor c'est aussi valable dans le
déroulement d'une histoire policière
cette ambiguïté vous l'avez vous l'aviez
aussi entretenue dans le doulos oui mais
c'était pas la même ambiguïté il n'y
aura pas d'ambiguïté quant aux
personnages dans ce film là c'est une
sorte de longue méditation sur la
solitude dans le doubs l'eau sans
ambiguïté
est à calculer pour chacun des
personnages pour chacun des
protagonistes de cette histoire on ne
savait jamais s'il disait la vérité ou
s'il mentait là les gens disent la
vérité dans celui là mais s'ils sont
seuls pendant situe le samouraï dans
votre oeuvre
c'est d'abord la fin d'un cycle c'est
mon dixième film en 20 ans je m'étais
toujours dit qu'il faudrait que j'ai
fait dix films en 20 ans j'ai commencé
le sciences de la mer le 10 août 1947
j'aurai fini le samouraï aux alentours
du 10 mai 1967
je ne pense pas que cela veuille dire
que les films que je ferai après son
très différent de ce que j'ai fait pour
tout à fait quoique on est en état de
perpétuelle mutation
une année plus tôt change toujours on a
une façon de considérer le métier qui
ont fait d'un petit peu plus près en
même temps que d'un petit peu plus loin
je crois que le cinéma a besoin d'être
traités comme on le traitait eau pendant
les années 30
ce que j'ai appelé l'âge de platine
schéma puisque l'âge d'or c'était le
cinéma mais je crois que les années
trente du cinéma américain sont une fois
pour toutes les bases sur lesquelles on
doit construire des films pour que le
plus grand nombre de spectateurs
viennent avez vous conscience d'aller à
contre-courant de la mode oui bien sûr
j'ai toujours été tout à fait opposé à
la mode
je ne sais pas ce que c'est que la mode
puisque vous avez utilisé le décor
naturel et maintenant vous ne voulez
plus haut mais je ne voulais plus
l'année après que je les ai inventées
c'est à dire que si on la méritait faire
le con tuerait les enfants terribles en
décors construits jeune j ai horreur du
décor naturel vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure le poésie il n'y a pas de poésie
dans un décor naturel c'est facile il
faut transposer tout à fait toujours
essayé de d'apporter une part de rêve
aux spectateurs ont dû montrant parce
qu'il voit tout le temps